[Music]
I hope everybody had a great Halloween I
hope you had a great weekend thanks for
you including me in your weekly routine
if you're just here for John heater
maybe you'll like the episode and you
can follow us and write a review
afterwards we'd appreciate that you
could follow us on the handles at Ryan
uh inside if you pod on Twitter inside
of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that is correct you can also
watch the show on YouTube which is
always fun please write a review please
follow us on our handles
um what else what else we got going on
we have the inside of you store a lot of
cool stuff new stuff merch autographed
Smallville stuff it's called the inside
of you online store
uh I'm on the Cameo if you want a
message for your friend or your brother
or your aunt whoever doesn't really
matter I do some of that and we're going
to be at some conventions Tom Welling
and I we're going to be in San Francisco
at the end of the month
we're going to do a Smallville nights or
we do a show together or a two-man show
um and then we're going to be in
Columbus and then Pittsburgh back to
back to back weekends at San Fran
Columbus and Pittsburgh I think
something like that but just check my
Instagrams Toms we're going to put out a
video with all that stuff
come visit us
it'll be fun today's guest is a good
friend of mine he lived here he was my
horror movie uh buddy and he moved away
and uh we have a fondness for horror
movies and that's how we became friends
we were at uh Universal Horror Nights
and uh yeah we hit it off great guy
Family Man
um
he was Napoleon Dynamite for God's sakes
legendary role Blades of Glory without
further Ado let's get inside of John
Peter it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenberg
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
it's just all I love shorts I love
wearing shorts my guest today is John
heater and he's getting comfortable
underwear all those shows
what are you gonna do I'm Gonna Keep
adjusting hey we wearing the same shorts
uh my we are wearing the same shirt
basically basically
um that was a great story wasn't it it
was we were uh yeah now you can explain
and it's not we you were I was in the
airport and I don't know what got into
me but this guy was loud on his phone
folks and uh he was just like you know
so so basically like he wanted everybody
to hear him but for some reason I
responded and I go so basically and he
turned around and was like give me the
finger I was like
you
and so he tells me the story and I'm
laughing because that's funny for a
number of reasons mostly because you
deserved it yes but he also went over
the top no he was people people talking
there he might have been annoying yes
but he would have deserved it had you
had company with you you were this is
Michael like he you're alone you're so
used to doing this with your buddies
that you forgot like you can't think
you're alone like not that you should do
that when you're with your buddies
that's straight up just a gang of
bullies but it's rarely you see solo
bullying because well I didn't exactly
easy to do stuff for the attention for
the validation for like of the their
peers they're like oh I want to look
tough in front of my peeps so they will
make fun of someone they will whatever
if I didn't make fun of someone straight
up mocked him well he was just so loud I
was like so basically and he's like yeah
phew and flick me off right wrong with
what I did
but I feel everybody wants to do that
but they don't I did but if I was there
I wish I could have seen this is
probably how it went down he's talking
he's passing you and you go so basically
and then you look to your two ghost
companions who weren't there you're just
like am I right or or even worse someone
else you didn't know pastor and right
they're like get off me you creep
exactly like I had nobody to turn to and
I just kind of looked at him and you're
gonna oh that's true did I say that out
loud and then he's thinking did I say
that loud anyway I thought I'd share
that story with you guys uh John
um was one of the first guests that has
spent the night at my house he spent the
night last night we he he lives out of
town he moved away he said he promised
he would come visit more but he has a
family a big family they live in um
Oregon and uh we technically live in
Washington right on the border right on
the border but you came down and we had
a big horror movie night we do our
horror movie nights and and we watched
uh black phone which we won't we won't
review what you just said the word and
now we have to say like I I just don't
want to like you know other than we
won't give spoilers but the trailer does
that enough yeah but I use everything
away all I'll say folks is I don't want
to get in the movie it's not important
about how good or bad the movie was it
is because you and I used to have a
patreon where we were reviewing it was
literally called where of all the good
horror movies gone horror movies you say
horror I say horror horror horror
it was aware of all the good horror
movies and we would rate movies because
we were just we love
a good horror movie but we they're just
hard to come by and so and anyway this
movie uh we I we we didn't really enjoy
it no we weren't it was it was a shame
too because I had to rent it it was 1999
and it looked nice yeah it looked nice
and there were some moments but I
thought Ethan Hawk was really good but
the movie was just lackluster anyway you
came down and you've been busy with your
life and I don't get to see a lot so
it's good to have you here
um
you know let's let's go back let's go
back a little to the beginning how it
all started because you were living in
you were born in Colorado right yes and
you grew up there no you grew up in
Oregon yeah how old were you when you
moved from Denver or from uh Colorado no
Fort Collins I was born in Fort Collins
uh I love having that connection but you
know whenever people are like sweet I
was like well we moved when I was two so
oh really so you have no recollection
yeah yeah no my dad was he was a doctor
and he then moved to we were conceived
in Japan well that'll become full circle
later on but what do you mean you were
conceived in Japan my parents right
before moving to Fort Collins Colorado
he was stationed he was in the station
in the military as a doctor in the
military right uh at a base in yokozawa
in uh just uh North Southern southern
part of Tokyo so they were uh stationed
there and we were conceived there they
moved to I always like to you know I
like that little you know brag those you
were made in Japan made in Japan made in
Japan so then we go to uh yeah Colorado
born there and then they soon moved uh
to Oregon and that's where we I spent
the rest and so your dad's a doctor when
you say doctor is a family physician is
he yeah so did he was he your doctor
yeah he was he was my doctor but the
Beauty and the funny thing about you
know kind of growing up in a family you
know where your dad's a doctor is like I
never went to the doctors I never went
because my dad would just like
do his checkups at home why would he do
like a cough connection no I mean you
have to have those eventually yes so I
think he just like could monitor us just
far enough away like all right like he
was always like the very chill because
remember I've told you this before so my
dad was a doctor it was perfect because
he was also the ultimate scout master
like growing up we were in Scouts and he
we literally just came from Oregon uh
for celebration for my dad uh we gave
him the golden Beaver award which oh
it's actually kind of a made-up award
the silver Beaver for those in Scouts
silver Beaver is like one of the highest
Awards you can get you would only get as
a leader not as a scalp but we kind of
made of this one the golden Beaver
because it's better than silver
but it was kind of our way of just we
got all of our old friends people that
were Scouts under him leaders and we
just got a like a group of like 70
people and we kind of commemorated like
my Dad's life we showed video we had
Memories We had people telling stories
uh it was really awesome and my dad you
know he really changed a lot of lives he
was incredible yeah you really look up
to your dad I mean I really it's nice
it's nice to see that the family just
all
supports you know your family is very
supportive you're all very for the most
part very close yeah yeah and he uh so
yeah being a scout master who's he was
put a lot of that and a doctor he put a
lot of emphasis on first date and it was
very much like
you know there's a famous story in our
troop growing up where we had this kid
who like they were out on a camping trip
and they was climbing over this old log
with a branch and he fell and impaled
right into his leg
and I mean blood was coming out
it's not what he did it's what he made
the voice the boys had come up like uh
brother heater brother here because he
was he was a heater it was a scout troop
but it was also through our church right
and so what do we do what do we do it
was like well you guys know your first
take start treating him for shock and
and he was just like you know what to do
he's like do you've been training and
you guys handled it well so I wasn't
there I was it was a favorite story I
wasn't there but like I know that I just
saw him again
um but yeah they treated him for shock
wrapped him up uh cleaned the wound and
uh and it was I mean it's a very famous
story every story about your father
because he was just like yeah you guys
do this you know what to do you know
what to do I've talked to the teacher
isn't it yeah oh yeah that would have
freaked me out though yeah so I know
you're right here you're a doctor no but
I don't care I get that you trained us
but this is and he was like no this is
not out of your room you guys can figure
it out so you're do I mean you you
really look up to your father like
you're you guys are very close was he
always very supportive of everyone in
the family and just like always loving
and was he that kind of father is that
he's the kind of father that was like
he he his father left when he was oh man
I should know this but it was when he
was he was young he was probably like
almost a teenager and he was the oldest
in his family
and then his dad left and so he um
and that's a whole nother story which
was really kind of came full circle a
few years ago when my grandpa when his
father died and we started to get to
know him but my dad was very forgiving
like after years and years of like
having been separated you know he
started spending time with him because
he knew he wasn't going to live much
longer and so wow so he embraced him
yeah and he probably resented him a lot
well I it's weird he never opened up
that much about his real he just never
had much of a relationship with his dad
and after his dad came like he moved to
Hawaii and had a whole another life in
Hawaii he left his family left and went
with uh another woman and then but then
he built a whole other life where people
like he did amazing stuff it really was
a lesson and learning like
like you left this family
and a terrible thing you went on to
start this other life where he his dad
was a doctor as well and changed
people's lives he saved this family like
and from an abusive relationship took
them under his wing and he got married
to this woman and then he had like a
whole new family it was an incredible
person did incredible things I still
meet people who sometimes like oh yeah
you're Dr heater your grandpa delivered
me like because he was a ob gyn as well
um but that's crazy yeah the
juxtaposition of like wow horrible he
leaves one family so you're like this
guy is an [ __ ] and then at the same
time he goes and it becomes this great
man somewhere else it was just it's odd
it's very odd and when we went to his
funeral
I started meeting you know family
members I'd never really talked to or
had ever met before and you just start
getting all these stories from both
sides and
and it's not that everything's Justified
or there was no answer there was no
Perfect Balance but it was but the but
the end of that was my dad forgave him
my dad forgive it was really incredible
and I think a lot of some of his other
70s some of his uh his other siblings
that hit you know worse but
um but your dad made the most of it and
became this great man that used to yeah
and in the last like 20 15 years of my
you know grandfather's life when he
moved back to the States they moved up
to Washington so he was only once stayed
away from my dad who was living in
Oregon so he would make trips up but he
wanted to have this relationship with
his dad and so coming around to
answering kind of your question like my
dad never wanted that he he saw what his
dad did and he was like I want to be the
kind of father who's around
but he's very he has he's a quite quite
dignity kind of describes a lot of his
Persona he was not we don't know where
where me and all my brothers and my
siblings my sister we were loud
rambunctious we were all into film and
making videos and being creative and
being into art and my dad didn't have a
scrap of that my mom you know she she
didn't really she was an artist like we
don't know where any of that came from
right and my dad who was just very you
know everything was logical and
everything was just like he was our
resident Vulcan you know he was just
like but I mean buddy he governed us and
he raised us and he loved us with
uh like if my dad
if we did anything wrong and my all my
dad he never like punished us physically
right or anything he was just like he
could give me a look like I'm just I'm
upset and that was enough that was it oh
yeah I wish my dad could have just given
me a look sometimes I get the hands and
the marks are still here
inside of you is brought to you by
Shopify I love Shopify guys
um you know this podcast we didn't have
much to sell in the beginning and it was
like a t-shirt and using Shopify is so
easy I thought oh I'm gonna have to give
it this to a company to handle and
they'd take a big commission and they're
gonna have to handle all the stuff but
Shopify makes it so easy uh easy for me
it makes it simple to sell to anyone
from anywhere that's what's great
whether you're a big business or small
business now I have tons of items to
sell I could tell which item is selling
the best the least
um how much money I've made how much
money uh it just there's so many things
and it's it's very easy it's just a
screen
and the top a list on the left of what
you need to do analytics let's see what
we're doing this month press it done oh
look at that uh I made this much this
month it's easy Shopify is glorious with
Shopify you'll create an online store in
your vibe
discover new customers and grow the
following that keeps them coming back
Shopify has all the sales channels
sorted so your business keeps growing
from an in-person POS system to an
all-in-one e-commerce platform even
across social media platforms like Tick
Tock Facebook and Instagram
and thanks to 24 7 support and free
libraries full of educational content
Shopify has got you every step of the
way yes whether your thing is vintage
tees or recipes for ghee start selling
with Shopify and join the platform
simplifying Commerce for millions of
your favorite businesses
worldwide it's how every minute new
sellers around the world make their
first sale with Shopify and you will too
huh Shopify makes selling simple so you
can put yourself and your ideas out
there whether your thing is making
ebooks or earrings Shopify makes your
success possible when you're ready to
launch your thing into the spotlight do
it with Shopify the Commerce platform
backing millions of businesses down the
street and around the globe go on try
Shopify for free and start selling
everywhere this is possibility powered
by Shopify sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com inside all lower case go go
to shopify.com inside to start selling
online today shopify.com slash inside
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
therapy online
the amazingly talented people who appear
on my podcast and me let's be honest may
seem like we have it all figured out
but we obviously don't navigating any of
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new relationship or becoming a parent
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual a trained therapist is the
next best thing therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
betterhelp has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
now I know your dad now was diagnosed
with Parkinson's yeah yeah and now
that's got to be a horrible thing I mean
how many years has he has he had he was
diagnosed boy it's probably fifth 10 50
oh man I it's weird it's just like
almost 10 15 years I'm not even entirely
sure but at least 10 years ago
um yeah he was diagnosed and uh
yeah I mean I mean the amazing thing is
you know he's lasted longer and done
better than of course they expected I
mean you feel like you hear that all the
time like
you know he uh oh it's not gonna it's
not gonna go as well or he'll go
downhill quicker and he's lasted a long
time our Gage and I was telling you this
earlier our Gage is like when does he
stop going on backpacking trips because
my dad you know again yeah I started you
guys we grew up you know in Scouts but
the big thing was he just loved getting
us Outdoors loved getting us camping
doing these you know physical activities
to learn first aid to learn you know
self-reliance to learn all these things
but you know it's still just uh we loved
it backpacking and so in our adult years
me and my brothers have tried to pick
that back up let's go backpacking let's
bring dad along
um and I think sadly this last year
might have been you know his last he
kind of told us like this might be the
last one because
yeah it's just he's slowing down and has
it hits you has it do you sort of have
you broken down about that I haven't
broken down I mean it's it's sad but he
you know he's still here and I don't
know I fear
I've never really lost anyone
yet that I've broken down my grandma his
his mom
was the closest like I started you know
like I am emotional person but I don't
cry a lot but I kind of notice you as an
emotional person well I can be like
certainly when I when I watch stuff like
you know movies I can get I could tear
up in movies and when I think about my
you know own personal stuff I can but I
don't it I'm waiting for the I'm waiting
for the moment when something happens
whether I lose my father or I lose any
of my kids or my wife you know I'm not
waiting for that right hopefully that's
way down though hopefully I never lose a
name you just never know it's inevitable
but right but I know that moment's gonna
come where I'm gonna break down maybe
you know
um yeah I mean I have broken down uh not
broken down it sounds weird like off to
the side of the road but sort of just
depressed or no and I'm definitely deaf
mo more in my adult years in my father
years yeah there have definitely been
times around my kids about my wife where
I've you know I've cried and
um you know during hard times so no it
happens but I think in terms of losing
someone
I think you know if
when my Dad or Mom go you know I you
know
yeah it's but it hasn't hit me yet
because he's still here I live closer to
him now I get to see him more often
um
and he
it's just it's a hard thing I I think I
live day by day yeah I don't know if I
can accept it like it's
I don't know but he's still there and
he's still mentally uh amazingly and I
don't know all the effects I know that
sometimes you know dementia can roll in
with any kind of you know
um disease or a situation but it hasn't
really hit him that way yeah he's slower
speeching he's quieter
um but he's still there he's still your
physician no does he not ever check no
he's done he's not yeah yeah he checks
me out so no I will still go I will
still we'll still go to him for you know
medical advice for sure when you've you
do you really say something because I've
never I've always kind of like I think I
got used to because I had a dad as a
doctor I never went to a doctor so I
just I don't even have a doctor now it's
terrible I should I need to get checked
up regularly because it's a good thing
to do he looks in the camera yeah but
anybody want to give John a checkup but
I I got so used to like yeah and
and uh I I need to so but if if
something's like wrong with the kids
like Dad what do you do again for this
what do you do right yeah what uh what
was their response because they don't
seem like they'd be like your your
parents were they really excited for you
or did they want you to get into acting
when you started like when you did
Napoleon and you showed them did you
show them the the short film that you
made in college with Jared Hess did they
see the short film did you show them
things that you were doing I
I must have showed them peluca the
shortcut was the original yeah I must
have showed it I was very proud of
paluka and I loved it and I must have
showed it to you because I showed them
all our videos so my you know my brother
and I we made videos all throughout high
school and I showed anybody I could show
it like anybody who's willing to watch I
showed it because that's what we do as
filmmakers you know so excited yeah yeah
well you think everything's great you
have to know your audience yeah and
that's a huge thing and even at a
younger age I think I had a pretty good
idea of who my audience and and my dad
has always been like he wasn't really
big into movies every now and then he
would take us you know to the but it
just wasn't him and so I must have
showed him I don't remember because it's
like dad's not gonna get this but when
Napoleon Dynamite became such a
phenomenon were they sort of like
because when when when when I hit
success my I took my grandparents to a
convention and there was a line wrapped
around and uh my grandfather goes who
are all these people in the line what's
wrong with it who are they here for I'm
like
I think they're here to see me and he
goes what the hell is this what is wrong
with me this is this is crazy he
couldn't it was mind-blowing and to see
the look on his face of like well my
grandson has some kind of accomplishment
here he did something that people
recognize and they like him yeah they
were blown away I took him to Planet
Hollywood for a Premiere once and they I
just seen the look on the face on their
faces made me happier than I've ever
been seeing how happy they were for me
made me happier than I could ever be so
did your parents when did they know
something's different it was a it was a
little bit of a um I say a curve it took
a little bit of time because but which
is interesting because Napoleon almost
I say Napoleon took a little bit of time
but in in the terms of
you know having it come out in June of
2004
but most people will tell you oh yeah
Napoleon was an overnight success right
even though it was it took its time but
it was like out of nowhere it felt like
it was an overnight success because it
came from nowhere right nobody was in it
that anybody knew right so yes it was
instant Fame but you know it still was
like
I did this movie my parents knew I was
shooting this movie
and they knew I was dabbling in the
acting and he was just like yeah well
that's what they did on their videos we
made videos and we directed them but we
would act in our act I'm doing finger
quotes right act in our videos we would
be on camera because I loved goofing
around in front of the camera as well so
it wasn't a surprise and my oldest
brother in my old and my sister as well
like they did like high school plays
they were all especially my oldest
brother he was into drama he was into
the school plays so that was actually
everybody thought he was gonna go and be
the actor
um
so when I just started doing it it was
just kind of like they knew we wanted to
get into Hollywood somehow right and
into the movie making so it wasn't that
big a surprise with that but we do
Napoleon Napoleon's coming out and it
goes to Sundance and Sundance I tell
everybody that's really when my life
changed everything changed was was
Sundance because that was the first
validation right that was the first
thing I feel what happened you went to a
screening for it it was the I you would
call it the premiere but it was that
Sundance it was the first screening
it was packed uh it was it was like one
of their biggest venues there
um as big if not bigger than yeah way
bigger than a normal was it the first
time you had seen the movie yeah I I'd
seen part I don't know if I saw the
whole movie but I saw a rough cut which
you know that early on in my career I
was like I cannot watch a rough cut
again of a movie I'm in yeah I know
because I was just like this is bad
they're like no no this sounds not done
the picture's not locked you know it's
hard to comprehend yeah so I um so I
just kind of put that out of memory and
waited for the first screening to really
you know were you nervous at the
screening I was not nervous you weren't
no Jared the director he was sitting
right you know I think right behind me
or next to me or whatever
he was nervous he was dry heaving
because this was his baby
he was dry heaving yeah he was like yeah
he was he was nervous he was absolutely
nervous and I was like
kind of thinking chair what like what do
you get to lose we're not anybody's
right now like we've got nothing to lose
so if it's no good if people don't like
it and then you know it's embarrassing
for a small amount of people in my life
right but I also knew we did the short I
believed strongly in the product I was
like dude I think if it's not great it's
not going to be terrible because they
just don't get it you know whatever
but we watched it for the first screen
it was just it was one of the most
memorable moments of my life
inside of you is brought to you by
Freedom grooming I I've said this before
but I wish there was a razor like this
when I was doing Smallville and they
were shaving my head
I was getting Nyx
and cuts and irritations Ryan ingrown
hairs Ryan blood trickling down my face
but not anymore with freedom grooming uh
you know one of my friends he's bald he
uses this he's like I wish I had this 10
years ago it makes everything so much
easier in your life at Freedom grooming
we make the flex series electric shaver
which is uniquely designed to flex and
Contour to the curve of your head for a
smoother faster and safer shave without
the risk of Nyx Cuts irritation or
ingrowns get the smoothest shave of your
life flexible blades Contour to the
shape of your head for a baby smooth
shave every time Shea 50 more hair in a
single stroke compared to traditional
razors expect shave time of two to three
minutes not 10 to 15. and never cut
yourself shaving again the flex series
Safeguard technology means no Nicks no
ingrown hairs and no problems and the
flex series waterproof design means you
could shave in the shower with or
without without shaving cream shave wet
shave dry since even the sharpest blades
dull with use Freedom created the close
shave plan with a close shave plan
you'll never run out of fresh sharp
blades delivered to your door every six
weeks with free shipping all active
close shave plan members are upgraded to
a lifetime warranty and it's completely
customizable adjust skip or cancel your
plan anytime ten thousand five star
reviews for Freedom grooming stop Deli
slicing your scalp with traditional
razors try Freedom today or get it as a
gift with your exclusive 20 off by going
to
freedomgrooming.com
inside that's
freedomgrooming.com slash inside inside
of you is brought to you by Geico Geico
asks how would you love a chance to save
some money on insurance well of course
you would after all who doesn't love a
great deal right and when it comes to
Great rates on insurance for all the
things in your your life Geico can help
like with insurance for your car truck
motorcycle boat and RV even help with
homeowners condo or renters coverage you
could save even more with a special
discount when you bundle your coverages
plus add the easy to use Geico mobile
app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to Geico becomes an Easy Choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
what was it like what was it like are
people coming up the first shot of the
film you know he's standing there I'm
standing there with the Trapper Keeper
waiting for the bus and that's when
people just like they started laughing
like immediately kind of like yeah kind
of chuckling and then because people in
an audience especially at Sundance and
they know they're with the filmmakers
people want to be the first to discover
something so they're willing they're
going out on a limb to take a chance
right they're willing to CH like be the
first people who are like no this is
awesome and then if it doesn't do well
then they might you know retract that
statement later but they want to be the
ones to say no I was the first one to
see it if it in case it does you know
find success yeah but I think it was
also just genuine people were laughing
and was Kirsten your wife with you yeah
she was with me well she's surprised
like oh my God like the response I don't
think she it was a constant laughter
yeah it was just like yeah it was going
great the whole screening went great and
it was building and building then you
know the dance scene is kind of like
when you that's the climax but it's also
the first time I was like that's where I
really put myself out there and it was
so personal to me like everything I
everything every line on the film Jared
Hess wrote right but the dance was all
me he just wrote how many takes did you
do the dance well that was just it was
three takes three takes yeah and you
came up with your own stuff that you
rehearse it on your own no no rehearse
we did like a little rehearsal of the
first like two acres right you remember
the dance I mean how do you not remember
the dance yeah it was uh it was just um
yeah it was just I just winged it it was
just all freestyle people lost it yeah
they loved it they loved it because
you're like this might
Jared and I were saying like you know
this dance better be
it's not just good but it's gonna make
or break hopefully it all culminates to
this moment
and if the dance isn't good because in
the movie The Audience loves it the the
high schoolers love it right and you
hope it matches the crap the real
audience watching it right so you're
hoping and after the dancing there's
that pause and the audience cheers and
then our real audience is cheering and
it was just like you know I felt like a
million bucks and I think after that
Jared was like okay I'm in the clear did
you feel like
um my life's changing right now
I mean had to I remember that feeling
when I was in high school and I would
admit show videos that I made right I
loved it I loved that film I would show
it to classrooms I would do class
projects and we put that up and it's
that feeling as a as a director you know
like or if any
if you're an actor or director
especially if you're the director of
producer you know you made the film
you get that high from just like this is
my audience and they're they're gonna
watch it and people are loving it and
you're doing it for you but literally
just watching this documentary on ilm
that we're watching the Star Wars and
these filmmakers like George Lucas
saying is like me and Spielberg and you
know Coppola you know we did like to
make movies for ourselves and a lot of
times like they're doing it to like you
know a lot of filmmakers get out of
there like I want to make the moves I
want to make but these I mean he
admittedly is like we are the filmmakers
trying to make movies for people the
audience we want to make movies for the
audience we want to see yes we're going
to enjoy it at the same time but we want
to wow we think we know what audiences
want and we want to wow them right and I
and that was just part of like you know
who I was and we want to make something
now Napoleon was kind of a personal
thing especially for Jared you know he's
making something that he needed to make
that for him hoping
well I don't know if audiences are going
to like this movie right so anyways yes
I knew my life was going to change why
yes why we've talked about this but I
just want to bring it up quickly
were you ever like why the hell wouldn't
he have done a Napoleon Dynamite too why
didn't Napoleon go to college
why didn't Napoleon do something else it
was such a blockbuster hit and they do
so many shitty movie sequels there's
movies now they make that the first
one's not even good or they make a
sequel of something from the 80s that
never was good and then they're and so
it's like you have such a huge success
right there right right what well that's
why isn't that why then we don't make a
secret because it well this was such a
big big success and the characters were
so lovable that you I was dying to see
them again well we made the cartoon yes
but the cartoon wasn't live action no it
was a live-action it was fun I loved it
it was great but
why do you think a were you a little
disappointed honestly B do you wish
there was
uh Napoleon Dynamite too and that's all
I just have to
uh no I was uh I was fine not doing a
sequel
um I we never you know when we made it
we weren't thinking in terms of like
like producers or you know marketability
or like franchise which I do remember
that said you know I remember pretty
earlier while we're shooting it we knew
we were on to something at least with
like all the dialogue in the lines like
oh man you could totally make like Uncle
Rico dolls and you could make Napoleon
dolls and pull strings and they all have
their different lines flipping idiot
gosh or yeah like back in 82 I used to
be able to throw pigskin quarter mile
you know whatever like they each have
their every character had their line so
I I saw that there was something with
these this colorful cast of characters
and you could there was could be a life
beyond just the film right right but I
wasn't thinking sequel I just thought I
was actually thinking merchandise I was
like yeah you could do merchandise but
which is so stupid because I should sign
something right then and there like you
didn't make emergency I think I made it
I think I made a little bit I don't even
I not much not not much it's negligible
so
but no when when they they started
asking what do you even think about a
signal nobody was even asking a sequel
in the beginning you know it wasn't
until like you know probably later that
year or the year after when my agents
were like well you know fox is like
they're they want to do a sequel like
would you be willing to do one without
Jared and I think they were just asking
because they they probably without Jared
well yeah because they were probably
feeling like uh I don't know if um
Jared's gonna be up for this and would
you say because he might have already
said no I don't know but what'd you say
I said no I wouldn't do without Jared
I was just like no because do you regret
that uh no I don't no no not at all
because this was Jared's this was this
was Jared's Jared I mean this was like
his life growing up and and pressed in
Idaho and it was very personal to him
and I've always you know respected out
of choice but also just naturally like
respected um like the idea that no this
is his baby he brought to me he brought
me in on this and I'm
eternally grateful that I'm part of this
family now part of this creation but
it's still Jared's and it's his vision
and and to do us a sequel without him
just it made no sense nobody I can tell
you right now none of the other casts
would have done it without him but if
you said yes they would have made it
if I said yes I don't know well but if
I who knows there's not a there was not
a world it was gonna if I also you know
you know all the other actors now like
we were close by that point we were like
all in it but we were all like yeah this
is Jared's thing there would have been a
world I wouldn't have said yes if I knew
there was a possibility that the other
actors would say no if I said yes I
don't think they would have
I don't know if they would have followed
me I just never would have said yes if
Jared wasn't involved it made no sense I
wasn't ready to make that kind of crap
right
um I understand because it would have
been crap you know if it wasn't Jared
and so
that's why and I think Jared was just
moving on trying to do other projects
what is uh what's the one line people
constantly ask you to say
uh well
yeah I think the number one line is uh
teeny fat large come get some ham is
that the one yes a hundred percent and
that one took me by surprise because you
know I thought
yeah the accessible lines like flipping
idiot gosh uh lucky all that stuff was
like yeah you can use that in so many
countless situations people are going to
be saying that
and then what I started hearing over and
over and over in t-shirts and people
come out just like Danny fella you know
what our favorite line at home is Tina
you fat it was just like what like that
doesn't make sense what's your favorite
so you have to have a Tina that you know
she has to be fat and it has to be
dinner time or there's got to be some
hamling or like there's so many Tina
come and get it but people are like oh
yeah we use it for everything
what's your favorite line my favorite
line is is the the crystals line
it's like hold on a second I forgot to
put in the crystals he's talking about
the time machine and he's just like he's
about to get this gun and it's just like
oh super super like extreme close-up of
his awkward fingers putting the crystals
in the little little like hole and he's
like put the oh yeah that's of course
the time machine requires crystals to
power when you when you do the Japanese
line with Japanese scientists explains
did you really flub up the line yeah you
did yeah oh no
yeah I think I flubbed that but like you
know I knew Jared and I were so in sync
like I knew he wasn't gonna cut I was
like yeah that's just we're gonna make
this as real you know this is what he
would do how bad did the shoes that you
wore smell at the end of the shoot
they were bad they were bad they were
like I don't remember the swell as the
smell as much as just the feel they were
falling apart yeah they tape them up
yeah we had to tape them up we had to
for the dance scene it's hard to see but
for the dance by the time we did the
dance because it was one of the last
things we shot right and there's tape
around one of the boots or possibly both
because the souls were starting to come
apart because we did a lot of running
you a lot of it is cut out of the film
but there was a lot of running uh where
I would just be in the middle of you
know Idaho and on a gravel road when I'm
like late for the dance or I'm fishing
for the bass for you know right for Deb
and I'm just running on gravel road and
it's just forever and just running
running running running and it's like oh
yeah those poor boots couldn't handle it
um you now are going on little tours to
places for screenings and doing Q and
A's with two cast members yeah Efrain
Ramirez yeah and John gries and John
Grice so you guys do these how many and
where do where are you going
oh we go all over I mean all over the
country we're waiting for the rest of
the world to catch on but I think I'm
convinced
that we are big in English-speaking
countries
okay it doesn't translate I don't think
it translates quite well to foreign
language like when they have to do a dub
it's just not the same when they're like
[Music]
you know like it's like that's your
Napoleon in Japanese yeah that's that
yeah
um I don't yeah I mean I would love to
you know travel the world obviously to
do some of that stuff and we have but
it's like New Zealand Australia England
good crowds though oh great crowds yeah
no I mean if you speak English you love
the movie and what uh where is people
get tickets to go do this
um
I don't know just maybe do you post on
your Instagram about it I should well
people need to know where it is where
the hell to go here yeah well they just
they they
um if it's near you you'll probably hear
about it somehow
jeez talk about lack of promotion that's
one thing I know I got it Well yeah if
it's near you I probably should you know
promote it um but I just never I don't
know well that's also one thing I've
always admired about you in a lot of
ways that you just don't ever get caught
up
in
the business whether it's social media
or just Hollywood you love how you love
Hollywood and certain aspects you love
movies you love your family you love
your friends and the balancing is pretty
remarkable I don't know anybody who it's
almost absurd how removed you are from
Hollywood but yet you're still in
Hollywood because you don't live here
you have a full family life you don't
really go on social media that much
you're just yet you're working
um how do you do that are you just not
interested in that no it's it is weird
because I I love I always wanted to work
in Hollywood where I wanted to make
movies and I wanted to get in that make
movies or or animate if you know I I
majored in animation yeah I was always
really into art I wanted to do art I
just wanted to create I wanted to create
and make you know fun stuff and awesome
stuff and so I I love I love Hollywood
for sure but
I think after a while you know we were
just like it's hot here it's so hot I
love the Pacific Northwest having grown
up there and so that's why we moved back
um but you know I'll tell you man I and
I I know I've probably told you this
before but
I've always felt like
no matter where I'm discovering like I'm
constantly an outsider constantly an
outsider in the way like not when I grew
up you know where I grew up in in Oregon
like it's great perfect child I mean it
was a great child I loved it I'm
obsessed with it I always tell people
like how much if I could match that
childhood for my own kids or whatever
you know I love that but you know moving
getting you know going to college in
Utah and getting uh the Napoleon gig
then moving out to LA yeah for sure I
felt like an outside oh I'm this you
know small town guy I'm not the smallest
town not a total like hayseed but kind
of like hey
um I did not grow up in Hollywood I do
not have Hollywood parents or or any
kind of pedigree that or family tree
that you know worked in the business so
I'm here I feel like an outsider I've
always you know the entire time I lived
here but not in a bad way I kind of
embraced it and loved like oh that's
kind of what set me apart a little bit
um but then you know again like for the
reasons I just explained we moved
finally and um and I love it up there
but I now feel like well I'm the
Hollywood guy or at least
it is in my blood to be like in
entertainment industry and up where I
moved up into Washington area it's like
there's not much of that no there's not
really much of that and once again I
feel like an outsider but again in a
good way like I love it
um you know people around me I mean boy
where we moved there's like countries
and farms and it's like some very
different vibe out there than out here
in LA and and I love them both I I yeah
it was hard to leave California I'm now
full on West Coast baby like just west
coast baby baby
uh California Oregon Washington I love I
love it all and they're all different
vibes
um but I uh
I don't know like I just yeah I've
always felt like an outsider and I think
that's how I always will feel but I
think a lot of people in a good way like
I I love that yeah
um no I get it I get it um D we've
talked about this before but you're not
a person who really gets anxiety are you
no it's it's crazy because
four kids
married balancing an acting career and
doing all these other things that you do
it just seems like every morning would
be anxiety
holy crap I've got four kids of
different ages and going through
different things and one shy and one's I
think it's I I almost feel like anxiety
is
the result
of not handling stress well like if you
get stressed and you let it get to you
then you have anxiety I don't know if
that's yeah but well I let it get to me
but it gets to me because and what I'm
saying is everybody will have something
to stress about every and yes I will
have stress but then I don't try not to
stress about it or at least let the
stress affect me too much you know how
do you do that I don't think I think
it's just a natural I don't know I don't
it's never I'm over raised do you think
has anything to do with it
self-reliance yeah it's so hard to say I
mean it could be I was always pretty
happy I had I attribute I look a lot I
always try to think like what made my
childhood what made me who I am and and
why did I feel I truly felt happy as a
kid yeah I think a big part was I have a
twin brother okay so I always think
about like I always had a playmate yeah
and in this case you know I know a lot
of twins are different my twin and I you
know were like we're the same but the
same in the way that it was it was
perfect because we like the same things
we had the same interests we had the
same talents and skills we were pretty
much the same at everything but instead
of becoming a really competitive and and
yes there's an probably an underground
competitiveness that lays there that
therapy would probably unleash like sure
a monster but but I don't know at the
same time it doesn't really like we've
also been very supportive of each other
yeah um and
but you know growing up as a kid you
always had a playmate you always had
someone there and I think that laid a
foundation and also my dad being a
doctor
and the scout master and even when he
wasn't he just felt saved I felt safe I
always felt safe like everything's gonna
be okay I think that's a huge yeah I
don't think I didn't feel that as a
child I felt like nothing's gonna be
okay yeah and everything is in chaos my
life is in chaos my family is chaos yeah
the world around me everything is okay
is chaos and I think that that has
affected me tremendously I mean it's
it's just it's it's you know product of
your own environment and I don't know if
that was my dad's thinking in his brain
but you know he was successful and he
just instilled that sense of security
but like okay but it's not just security
it's safe it's just like okay I felt
safe even though we maybe sometimes
physically we were doing crazy stuff and
he had us go on trips but more like the
future like everything's gonna work out
you know but it's also I think in large
part due to my faith you know and like
believing in that you know
like good will come from our good acts
but even then like if you are good at
heart and you're doing your best
you're enduring to the end as we say and
you are doing your best to
keep the Commandments to uh to do good
unto others and to you know and just all
around be a good person and to do good
and to be kind and do all these things
um and to follow you know be a
christ-like you know person
following his footsteps and and be like
him and and I think that encompasses all
the great stuff about just loving
everyone and anyways yeah everything I
say just trying to do good then all will
be good
yeah and even if you don't experience it
and there are certainly things I've you
know like there are times where I feel
like you know whether it's been hopeless
or just like oh man this sucks or I
don't know like
I just always feel like you know what
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
and that's what I'm trying to do with my
kids like
and my family is just like I'm not my
dad I'm not I'm not as smart as him I'm
not as talented as them I'm not as like
I'm just not him I don't want to put
myself down but you know more talented
with my father I can't create that same
kind of
house and you know and so I'm always
like if I can just help my kids feel
like they're safe and that everything's
going to become as long as they are
trying to do their best to be good you
know yeah
um then you know you're gonna be okay
and but trust in yourself push yourself
you gotta push yourself you gotta try
new things you gotta like get out there
and and just you know explore and do
uncomfortable things to help yourself
learn and grow and expand your mind and
your body and and your spirit
um yeah that's cool yeah I like you know
look every you know different things
work for different people and I've seen
religion where it doesn't work and I've
seen religion where it works you have a
close family you've all
on a church since you're you know since
you're tiny and it's worked for you it's
worked for your family there's a lot of
things that work for you you know and
it's also I like when you don't see
people always saying you should be this
you're you you're you're a Jew you
should be a Mormon you should you know
you don't like
you know you know what's the word
you don't uh
preach yeah you Don't Preach yeah
um let me ask you this have you ever
been Starstruck
um
yeah yeah
I don't know ever struck dumb it's not
star struck down but just I've always
played it cool I've always been like
yeah no that's great there's I can tell
you the few little times I ran into Ali
G uh Slash American yeah I had a par
early party like early in my career
right and I found that if I was running
into people that I felt maybe they're
not as big here in the states or like or
something I just been watching I don't
know like I just remember running into
him and thinking whoa okay and at the
same party there's you know Mel Gibson
or there's uh you know huge names and I
think they're incredible amazing but I
didn't get Star Trek maybe because I
wasn't meeting them you know right but
but even if I was it was just like you
know I don't know like running to him
that was a little Starstruck I got a
little Star Trek I I was he cool yeah it
was very cool but it was very brief it
was just like hey man yeah hey okay and
then we go this is Patrick Stewart
oh really oh yeah because I've always
like a loved Star Trek next Generation
grown up Patrick Stewart I've always
been like and I would tell people if I
could meet someone I'd love to meet
Patrick Stewart and I finally ran into
him actually he played my dad in a movie
he played my dad we didn't share any
scenes what was that it was uh Walt
Disney one yeah it's called Christmas no
no no it was called Christmas Eve it was
like it was small independent film you
know and it was kind of like one of
those where it's all these different
intertwining stories so I never shared
any scenes with him I never met him
during production I didn't meet him
until we
um we did the uh like premiere for the
film yeah right and it was I mean
it was amazing but it I don't know it's
like because we didn't sit and have a
lunch I think I would be more Starstruck
if we could be have a one-on-one right
because then you're like it's pressure
it's like oh James Cameron was one of
the other really amazing like I went to
a private screening of Avatar Wow when
he was right before he was coming out in
theaters at his my friend won a like
what auction there was an auction where
he got tickets to a private screening
that James Cameron's personal theater at
his at light storm
and so I go there with my buddy
and he's there and he does and it's only
like you know 15 maybe 20 people just
like a very intimate audience wow and he
goes he enters the films afterwards I'll
do a little q a you know no problem so
he comes in after the film and he just
like hey
and he's like answering questions and I
was like all these people are licking
his butt they're just ask they're not
even asking questions they're just
saying oh it's amazing what you're doing
with this phone was like I'm gonna ask
him a real question like a geek so I
asked him about like it's like so I
heard about this really involved process
that you did with the motion capture
sensors for the face to capture the
facial movements I was like you want to
talk about that or exactly how did you
exactly do that and he looked at me and
he's like oh that's a great question and
then he pauses like you're John heater
aren't you I was like oh my gosh and so
that was a huge wow like he was like
saying oh yeah me and my family were
fans
um that was that was a Starstruck moment
for sure well what about working with
Will Ferrell well yes I mean
but then you don't think if yeah I guess
I mean yeah sure Starstruck but I don't
think it's not Starstruck dumb like the
first time we met was on the ice it was
for training so he because
he didn't get a he didn't get uh
connected to the film until after I did
like uh originally it was gonna be Ben
Stiller and I and then Ben couldn't do
it so you know but Ben was producing
he's like don't worry John we'll get
someone else I was like I was so bummed
and then he was like oh we got Will
Ferrell I was like okay that's pretty
cool I guess I know you didn't no of
course no I was like I was just like oh
my okay that's pretty sweet because so
yes
but the first time we met because he was
so humbled I think humbled by the ice
right I was just like he was I just
remember he's like you ready to do this
and I was like this is a perfect thing
for him to say because I could see kind
of the excitement but also he knew like
I was I don't know like I he was a
really cool senior in high school with
the Letterman's jacket and I was Lucas
the nerdy little freshman who was being
taken under his wing and it introduced
me to all his like cool high school
buddies like could you tell Will liked
you was there something as you tell he
like or was it just business and he was
like Hey great seeing you like or did
you guys hang out or what come on dude
what's not to like
what's not to like no I yeah he was I
mean I think he liked me I mean he
didn't seem he was very down to earth
not at all he didn't BS BS anything like
he was very kind and sweet and did he
make you laugh a lot oh yeah I mean it's
like but he wasn't trying he was just
like he was a filmmaker like he was just
like oh like let's do this if you think
about it and like all right let's do
this thing but he was also kind of like
just chill and like would make jokes
we'd laugh about people on set or like
oh what about this guy and we try things
out
I loved working working with uh it was
it was a dream come true yeah
um and you know I learned a ton but yeah
he was I think he liked me uh I will say
this I will say this this is cool
so you know unlike a lot of other you
know I've worked with a lot of people
and I don't keep in contact with most of
them I mean not out of choice it's just
like you know Will's on a nether level
and and honestly I don't have his number
I never got a suffer we were thinking
sharing stuff so but I years later years
later this is the first time I had seen
him
like there was something we were trying
to produce and get made back in 2010 so
I saw him then or 20 2009 right so it
was years later this is a couple years
ago we I go to this um
uh screening in La for a show that he
was in and but he was a small part in it
but I was invited regardless by I think
my management so I bring my buddy and
we're going and it is my buddy who's not
in the business at all I was like this
would be fun to bring him here there's a
lot of people it's just it would be a
fun thing to watch so we're walking
around and in the after party you know
they have all this tents set up and I
finally see Will and he's in the back
back corner kind of alone
and you know admittedly looking kind of
tired and a little grayer that I
remember but it was just he was tired
and and he wasn't standing he was just
sitting the whole time and everybody
around him was like you know standing
and talking to him but it wasn't a huge
crowd I don't know like it was just he
probably just wanted it to be kind of
quiet alone
but and I was like sitting there with my
buddy I was like dude you had to go like
you did a movie with them I was like I
know I know but I never liked bothering
people I just like especially at parties
like I don't even bother them but it is
a party he wouldn't have come if he
wasn't ready to socialize a little bit
so you went over so I was like fine I
was like but I did say to my friend like
watch this watch this like see him
because the interesting thing he wasn't
standing up at all he wasn't standing at
all and I'm guessing he was just tired
and like oh people can sit down or talk
to me I was like dude watch this he's
gonna stand for me so you know I walk
over there finally I was like dude will
I you know we lock eyes and he's just
like
like the big eyes and she's like John
and he stands up and gives me a big hug
I was just like looking at my friends
like yeah yeah no no I was just like
yeah and it was great to have that
reunion and it was like oh I mean he'll
always have a special place in my heart
and I hope I have the same place that's
nice
uh lastly before we get into these some
patreon [ __ ] talking questions with John
heater
uh I know you hosted Saturday Night Live
and you say you don't really get nervous
you say you don't get anxiety I don't
know how one wouldn't get a little
anxiety when they're going on National
Television to do Saturday Night Live you
had to be nervous yes I was nervous for
style life but in the good way like
I remember this the exhilar it was
exhilarating which to me what felt like
a mix of like
you're nervous but it was just I felt
like it was in good hands they were all
so prepared and so like this is what's
gonna happen this is what's gonna happen
and it was it was a weird ride I'm
telling you like if it was now I would
be more I feel like it would be more
nervous but I'd be more professional so
maybe I wouldn't be as nervous there I
was just kind of writing the coaster I
was always professional like but I would
probably you know input more jokes and
put more writing but come up with more
you let them do their thing yeah it was
just like hey I'm kind of here along for
the ride I don't know what I'm doing and
uh but I'll do my best but I was so
young and still green and I just I mean
creatively I still had a lot to you know
really
kind of you know Blossom I suppose you
know
um so it was a great experience but I
was definitely like
I was nervous leading into it but also
like using those nerves and just like
let's ride this wave baby and uh and
have fun and it was it was a blast I
mean I was like I'd easily do this again
wow did you hear that Lauren I'd easily
do this again
uh that's amazing it just seems like
gosh there's so much going on Lauren's
like yeah okay do another hip moving or
maybe I'll let you in yeah get in
another hit movie uh this is [ __ ]
talking with John heater these are my
patrons lovable patrons who get to ask
questions and uh thank you go to
patreon.com inside of you to become a
patron I'll message you I appreciate you
support the show I love you thank you
here we go this is uh Megan H heater
what's the update on horror movies
latest ones you've watched liked didn't
like Peter she says it like we're good
friends maybe she follow us on
I feel like that's what people say when
they really know a heater heater or
friends
what's the update on horror movies well
let me just give you an update on one
movie a black phone no we watched one
last week that um the cursed the curse
was great I thought it was okay it was
good no I didn't think it was okay I
thought it was good better than okay we
also saw it was pretty fun
um what was the one with the kids have
powers
X-Men No oh that's why it makes sense no
it was called
the kids remember the in the old
apartment building and the you know they
dropped the
animal through the stairwell oh my gosh
why am I blanking on this are you sure
did you not watch it with us wait
dropping animals the Innocence oh I
missed that one yeah that was pretty
good it was actually the one I missed
that was dark um yeah I don't know
um
it's not scary though no but the first
hour's the worst movie you've ever seen
in the last hour is one of the best
you've ever seen yeah so stay with it
Maya P what are the best pranks you've
pulled on each other
oh man you know I really I feel
pressured I'll tell you this in
Hollywood I feel pressured to be a
prankster
because everybody everybody every St
every stupid like junket that you go to
press junket they're like what kind of
pranks you guys do on set I've never
been a prankster I've real and I don't
know I was like I feel like this should
be in my nature I'm a really I like to
think of myself a really fun guy I think
pranks just feel mean to me and yet you
know people get a good laugh as long as
it's safe but it's still like I'd rather
laugh with someone than ask someone not
to say that pranksters are bullies but I
just I don't know I'd rather put my
creative juices into
something I feel like I think I fear the
repercussion really oh yeah
they're gonna get me back and I'm like
and I can be a good sport that's one
thing I will say about like when I did a
um all this years ago
um when Ashton Kutcher show punked
punked
yeah I remember when that was out and
that was popular and it was like but
seeing the show I was like this like it
brought out the worst in these people oh
yeah like you just see them like lose
there they tried to punt me many times
and Chris they kept going to Chris our
friend Chris McDonald yeah who um and he
never anything I go Chris we want to
punk him we want to punk him we want to
punk him and he was like he wouldn't do
it he said no I'm not like what do you
mean he wouldn't he wouldn't let them do
it to me why not because he knew that I
would probably lose it I'd lose my [ __ ]
I would not look good now I was like I
remember when it happened thinking after
it happened I was like wait I but also
leading up thinking like almost like am
I gonna get punk no like I'm not a name
I'm not like a big enough name so I kind
of felt safe but then it when it
happened I still felt good about the
episode because I was did not lose my
because they're like if you do any I
mean they're like what if we ruined his
card it's like my brother who they went
to he's like well he's got a pretty
crappy car he won't care or what if they
do this I doesn't care about that like
you can't I can't really get you I I
don't think I would get ever like you
know pissed like this my [ __ ] some of
the things they wanted to do I was like
uh Chris R what would be your dream
project to work on
um
my dream project would be oh man I mean
I still would love to do a
I would love to do like a Sci-Fi Action
sci-fi movie maybe with some action I
did I mean I did my first real action
film a couple years ago that Tremors
movie yeah yeah Tremors five seven seven
September seven I didn't get that on
Netflix folks
um it's fun yeah I mean but it was like
it was finally doing like something with
like I didn't have a gun but I had like
a chainsaw I had blow torch I I mean not
a blowtouch but a a flamethrower
um and you're running around doing
stunts I love doing action I really did
love doing action I would love to do
more of that and I love sci-fi I would
love to do a Sci-Fi
um I don't know exactly like you know it
would be amazing to work with uh the
Coen Brothers obviously it would be like
a dream come true oh yeah Dana asks if
you can remake a scary movie what Would
You remake
I don't want to remake stuff I want to
make new things no I would remake a bad
movie make it good right how many movies
I'm trying to think of a movie we've
seen like now that could have been good
um
no like
um if I could remake a scary movie
what's uh
like
I want to make that would be awesome
they made a movie no one's made a good
wendigo movie like they wendigo when to
go oh if you know your Native American
lore from the Pacific Northwest it's
that you know
the wendigo some people went ego oh
pronounce it windy go uh they kind of
they made a couple of really you know
bad movies but so I guess I would take
one of those and try to remake it but
make it cool all right
the chief
where do you disagree or differ on your
horror preferences compared with Rosie
oh my gosh it's all horrible horror
based well
on our preferences
um they nicknamed me John hater
sometimes we do we say hate her because
he hates a lot of he hates everything no
I just I think with these guys our group
and with Rosie I can be a little bit
more honest because I'm always pretty
like I TR I think with film I'm a little
bit more critical which which is weird
because I love film and I will be
positive but I love what it can do and
when I see the possibilities I'll kind
of hate on something even if I love it
right
and try to be positive but like I'm a
little bit more I think I am more
critical and yet there's been projects
that I like that you don't like so I
don't know exactly where we differ
you're more like you really want some
good scares jump scares and I was scared
I want tone I want like to be creeped
out like almost the entire film like I
don't care if it doesn't have a jump
scare and but if my I think we're both
looking for our hairs to stand on end
for sure for sure
um and that's that's what we we've both
been looking for but I'm a little bit I
don't mind mood as much yeah and a slow
burn it can take its time if it's got
some cool moments I'll be more forgiving
of subtitles yeah
usually the subtitle movies are good A
lot of times yeah we watched that found
footage movie that was pretty good we
all liked and then there was another one
I forgot what is called Titus tinnitus
oh Titan Titan Titan and that was wild
that was weird oh my gosh anyway well
dude I I liked having you here I know we
only got to hang out for a day but uh it
was a lot of fun we went swimming
we went uh for a hike we had movie
Nights we didn't do anything wrong Dives
what are our old Dives Earl Dives is
your basement so yeah we watch Doc the
ilm documentary on Disney plus we had
friends over your brother was here it
was good it was good to catch up yeah
finally did the podcast the right way
the right way yeah he did it a long time
ago but it's not available the first he
deleted it because I was so unruly and
he was all over the place he was all
over I was trying to like all right I'm
one of his first guests but I'm gonna
show people like I can like do is lay
down and do whatever because I was also
calling I was like we literally just had
this everything you're asking me
everything I talked to you yes normally
everything you've talked to me about
this before and I'm like why do we have
to talk about don't know this
they don't know yeah but uh it was a
real treat thanks for allowing me to be
inside you buddy thank you man thanks
John
love the guy it's one of my besties in
the world uh
he just cracks me up I don't know he's
he's just uh he's a good dude
he's able to just get out of the adult
mode and just be a kid a lot just be fun
and I like people who are fun and laid
back at the same time it's easy to roll
with it you're not trying you're just he
finds me funny I find him funny we just
get along and we both hate many horror
movies because they're not good uh at
the time of this recording I don't know
what Jason was able to use of the wide
shot but I forgot to focus the wide shot
on this entire episode if you were
watching I apologize about that oh well
you're just gonna have to go back and
forth and that's that's what it what it
was I I hope I'm sure he found a work
around I'm sure it was great hey guys if
you're uh listening and you didn't
listen to the intro there's a lot of
cool information about the new CD cons
that I'm going to listen to the intro
again if you need that information
handles write a review for the show if
you liked it I really appreciate you
right now the top tier patrons we're
gonna we're gonna say their names out
loud they make this podcast possible
they have supported the show since the
beginning many of them and uh without
them I couldn't do the show and thanks
for the support for talkville our new
podcast we're trying to keep that going
so thanks for the support a lot of the
patrons from inside you are also patrons
of talkville uh go to
in society.com
patreon patreon.com inside of you to be
a patron and really help the show it
really it really helps here we go shout
outs Nancy D Leah Anna Sarah V little
Lisa you Kiko
Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W
Sophie M Kristen k
uh you know I think we forgot to send a
box she's a top tier and she's been a
good friend and she's she sends me stuff
and her and Liam made the pillow I'm
sitting against and I just want to give
her an extra shout out Kristin k
we love you you know that
we're gonna mess up we're going to
accidentally not send a box or something
might break or
and also if you order something how am I
supposed to know who it's for if it's if
if the shipping label says your name
that's who I'm gonna write it to on the
mugs or the things sometimes they're
like I didn't want it for that person
how was I supposed to know sorry Raj C
Joshua D Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly e Mike e l damn
Supremo 99 more Santiago am Chad W
Leanne P Janine R Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Chris H Dave H Sheila G Brad
d Ray H Tabitha T Tom and Liliana a
Talia and Betsy D yeah
Chad L Marion Dan n big Stevie W Angel M
Rhiannon see Corey K devnecks and
Michelle hey Jeremy C Andy T gavinator
David C John B Brandy
Carlisle D all right Camille asks Joey M
Eugene in uh Leah correct Nikki G Cory
Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan T Mel s
Orlando C Caroline R Christine s Sarah s
Eric H Shane RMR Jeremy V Andrew M
zoduichi 77 or a c is it or
c-o-r-a-c-i-e or a c
Chris R Karina n Michelle D Amanda R
Amanda s gen B Kevin e Stephanie K Lena
82 Jarrell jorel and Billy L thank you
Billy thanks for being a patron I really
appreciate you guys thank you so much
and uh
yeah continue to listen continue to
support I don't know what else to say
there's so many podcasts and uh you
choose this one to listen to
um
you know after a while when people say
they really like the podcast I start I'm
starting to believe it starting to
believe that people actually like this
podcast good it's hard because you know
it's uh you know you can again you
compare oh well that guy gets millions
of listeners and this guy I have my
loyal listeners and that's all I need
all I need is people who want to listen
and they give
and hopefully I'm giving and it's a
mutual love and respect Mutual giving
Mutual giving yeah uh I am Michael Rosen
from the Hollywood Rosenbaum from the
Hollywood Hills in California I'm Ryan
Taz
a big wave of the camera we love you
um be good to yourself and uh thanks for
listening I'll see you next week
[Music]
thank you